Wow some people can watch us interview
and be like oh my this girl is so funny
or they're gonna be like this girl is
annoying turn this off rice but isn't
that kind of who you are of course but
in the words of Daniel stab you're
either gonna love me or hate me there's
no in-between with me Claudia ashrae is
obviously unapologetically don't put
that out herself I'm very much inspired
motivated and inspired by franchise
would you ever want to go be a real
housewife like you get 40 something it
is my dream and I don't think I have to
wait till 40-something I think that's
like the housewives really need like a
millennial injection I think that's what
they were trying to do with like Tinsley
Mortimer I don't think I have to wait
like I am a housewife I live in New York
like I'm ready but I don't know if
they're ready for me but like I go into
meetings with my teams and I'm like we
are getting on the housewives and
they're like really I don't think I'm
like that's what we're doing get on
board or get out that's the big bucket
list item it is actually and I feel like
I don't know I could go I could tour for
like the next five ten years and like
retire on the Real Housewives that would
be a good life for me
well you might have to wait for that
dream to be a reality but this dream is
happening right now you never know I
might break out into song dance so I
need lots of space et met up with the
influencer turned comedian at the
theater at Ace Hotel before her big la
show I want to go back to the moment you
knew you were funny do you know what
moment that was wow that is such a good
question and one I've never been asked
before um I don't know I think it's
there's a very thin line between being
funny and being annoying and I think in
high school I was very self-conscious of
that line because I thought I was
hilarious but now I'm looking back and
I'm like oh everyone thought I was so
annoying and obnoxious so I don't know
when I changed from being annoying to
being funny but I think it was sometime
in college when like you have to learn
how to hone your craft I broke up with
my boyfriend like literally 20 minutes
ago we were in that lesson he just said
he couldn't commit to you what do you
mean you can't commit me like you walk
into clubs all these girls won't hook up
with you when you're an extrovert like
me you're a lot like an you can't stop
talking and it took me a while to be
like self-aware enough to know that you
don't always have to be at a hundred
like people find that annoying now I
know that all right so you were driving
the bus at a hundred right for a long
time for a long time but you have a time
when you were little or when did you
realize comedy was something that you
could use to your advantage I guess it's
very much thirsty at a young age like
sent a camera up in the limelight for
the spotlight so I think from a young
age I knew I liked to entertain people
and make people laugh
but like every kid does so I don't think
I'm special but I was always just like
loud and annoying and funny and I always
liked attention nothing has changed when
I guess then did you realize that you
could make a living being so I have been
on Instagram and you know influencing
for a while when I realized I wanted to
take a pivot into comedy so about 18
months ago I just did my first show I
did that Caroline's on Broadway I didn't
know if anyone was gonna buy tickets and
at first I was so nervous I'm like okay
I need to sell tickets any to sell
tickets and then the show sold out like
in a minute so then I was like oh I got
to put together a show then I was like I
gotta be funny and that's the hardest
part there's two huge hurdles I'm going
on tour like one making sure people show
up and then two making sure they have a
good time the latter is much harder to
do but it's one that I find really
exciting I don't think I'll ever be
comfortable you know basically being
like a dancing monkey for people but I
love it now you really rode this wave of
you hit like you hit everything at the
right time like Instagram came out when
you were in a right space yeah advantage
of that platform before Instagram when
you went to college what was the plan
where were you what were you gonna do so
this is gonna shock millions of
Americans but I was a physics major
physics means yes I was like the only
girl and it was so hard and I just
really liked science which is so weird
cuz now I would rather die than do
anything like smart so that's what I was
doing and then I started a girl with no
job my freshman year and by like my
junior year I was like making money and
like it was turning into a business I
was like I should really have a more
appropriate college degree so I switched
to media and communications in my in my
junior year which was you know also a
useless degree but it was better I guess
I don't know what I would have done with
a physics major would have been a good
backup plan now that I think about it
like if all this ends one day I could go
be a physicist right well what was the
dream job as a business
you know that's an interesting question
Bryce I don't particularly know but I
had high hopes for myself and honestly
I'm really proud of myself for that
you've been on a pretty wild ride yes
can we take it back a year and a half
do we have to it no I'm kidding yeah you
got cancer I did which was in hindsight
one of the best things that ever
happened to me as a person and also like
in my career like it just changed
everything for me in a positive and
negative way
um but back then it was like the worst
day of my life like I wanted I wanted to
die it's so important for you guys to
know that that's not who I am and if you
give me the opportunity to show you who
I am and what I stand for I would be so
grateful was there a moment where you
thought I'm never gonna get to do
anything again no because just as a
consumer of pop culture I've seen people
you know rise from the ashes I've seen
people get canceled and come back it
wasn't that it was just like it's just
what I want to do I really thought I
didn't have like a thick enough skin for
it and there was like a couple weeks
where I was just planning on like not
coming back I was like this is too ugly
like people were saying the most
horrible things about me like and just
stating them as they were facts which is
so frustrating cuz you just want to
respond to everyone but that's not a
healthy way to live so I was really
thinking I'm like I think you know this
industry is not for me I can't handle it
some people can't handle it and like I
didn't think that I could but I guess I
did how did you I don't know it's like I
blacked out for six months and I don't
even remember that time because it was
literally so hard in so dark so I don't
remember what I did or how I came back
from it but I just did were you thinking
of what's the back-up plan where he was
like I got to go back to get a physics
degree I was like I got to go to law
school like that's what's so crazy about
the about cancel culture in general it's
like people don't realize when you like
attack someone and whether it's deserved
or not and like wanna like ruin their
career like people don't realize it's
very much a career and I think when it
comes to like celebrity people are like
oh who cares but it's still I don't know
it's still there's still something
soaked up about it like so I just hate
the mentality of like dancing on
people's graves which is like the
generation that we live in like people
live to do that and I don't and I think
maybe before my experience I was like
living for canceled culture then having
been through canceled culture and
realizing how it's so much it's so like
not one-dimensional there's so much more
to it I know I'm always like on the
defense of the person being cancelled
because you never know
coming on behind and like there's so
much misinformation being spread so I
know when it comes to cancel call turn I
talk about it like I don't know if what
I always have to say is the most popular
opinion but I come from like a super
unique experience where like I went
through it I learned this important
lesson in a very public way and I paid a
very public price for it um which I'm
grateful for like I think that a lot of
people my age like that is a lesson that
you need to learn like don't be when
you're a kid and expect it not to come
back to you so what was I guess the
number one takeaway from that time that
you were like moving forward to do
better I'm going yeah well I guess you
never realized how big your platform is
until you do something wrong because no
one's praising you when you do cool
interesting fun philanthropic things
there are only the loudest when you're
doing something wrong so it sucks that
it took me like such a negative
experience to realize how powerful my
voice is but I think the thing I learned
that was most important it's like people
can change and people can grow Jameela
Jamil said it perfectly and they don't
want to miss footer but it's like as
long as you're learning and like trying
to improve and grow and your ignorance
like there's so much value in that and
people don't appreciate that enough so
that's what I learned from the entire
experience which I'm grateful for
do you know the moment where you knew
everything was going to be okay I think
when I came back on stage I had launched
six shows at Caroline's and after the
fourth one we got cancelled and I
cancelled up his show and then I
postponed it and we sold the tickets and
it sold out and I was like oh they're
still people who believed in me
and getting back on stage that first
night was like oh my god the most
awkward I wanted to die moment but I'm
so glad that I did because so much
happened from it but it took a lot of
courage like step on that stage when
like so much had happened and nobody had
heard from me and then I just like
popped out by Caroline's let me show you
guys I'm here but I'm really glad that I
did it because we're at the 8th now yeah
we're right here right now we are here
right now we're sitting in your dressing
room what is on Claudia fries right or
when she comes to a performance okay
it's incredibly embarrassing it's
chicken fingers french fries a Caesar
salad it's not for me don't worry it's
for my sister a diet coke like a case of
Diet Coke and then also always a bottle
of tequila also a fan is very much
important on my rider cuz I'm like a
over I'm sweating right now like I'm
always wedding and it's my least
favorite thing to sweat so I like sit in
front of the fan like with my legs open
just like before the show being like
let's go yeah what's the full pre-show
ritual the pre-show ritual ritual is
listening to a lot of music but in the
fan
like literally about my dress reading
over some material that I wrote I
usually write material on the plane
before I get there
and I pray with my sister would you like
a little handshake and then I get like
three minutes to myself and I just smile
and power hose
is that an honest thing or is that like
a fake it till you make it like power
pose so I put the power post at a young
age and I was really impacted by like
the message behind a power pose and then
they looked it up recently and like
psychologists have like really debunked
that it doesn't work but I'm a firm
believer that it works you're like maybe
you're the exception to the rule
yeah it's like if you look powerful you
feel powerful and there's something
about just like putting your hands on
your hips like Wonder Woman vibes that I
totally believe it is it weird to be a
part of pop culture now it ruins it
because like I went to Jackson
Brittany's wedding which was so much fun
but like I'm over here talking about
Lisa Vanderpump like every day of my
life and then I'm at this wedding
standing on a cocktail table next her
and I literally had to run away like
when your real life in your online life
like start to meet it's terrible okay
it's awful obviously you had to change
it all how you operate in the world I'm
definitely more reserved now that like I
will have the opportunity to run into
someone like I could have just been
talking about on my podcast so it
changes it changes you they say things
hasn't changed you but if it does you're
on Entertainment Tonight I think you're
allowed very true I think you're allowed
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday we've
got a digital show and podcast a hit
tour what's next what's next on the
bucket list we're gonna wrap up the tour
in January which is bittersweet the
thing with the Internet is like
consistency is key so like keep turning
out content seeing what sticks you throw
at the wall of Simon's on a stick is
there something that's kind of in the
back of your brain like I want to try
that next well I just released my song
which was very much like a creative
experience for me I'm ready to loose and
I think maybe I need to release a full
album okay devote some time to like be
in the next Erika Jayne the Jewish Erika
Jayne the chubby Jewish Erika Jayne I
think the world is ready more than ready
I think they're too okay so we might be
dipping more into music maybe why not
try it out look like a book oh for sure
I got so much say I can't stop talking
but the tour has been has been a lot of
work so I think once it's over and all
the travels behind me I can really
devote more time to other projects
remember if I was like watching an
interview data over the podcast you did
but you said you feel like you give away
yourself all day every day to the
followers the toasters and you get home
to Ben and faeo and you have nothing
left to give it's terrible I said to
myself I'm like I do the show every day
I go on tour and then I'm just like out
and about and I'm meeting people who are
listeners or followers and like I'm
always on for them because I don't them
to meet me and be like oh she's done you
know like part of my job is just being
on all the time and being president and
then I find when I get home I'd like
nothing left to give
for like myself for my husband for my
dog who's so important to me and that's
something I'm trying to work on moving
forward but like to me my job will sadly
always come first so it's just that's
one of the small prices to pay for being
in this industry that's more one of
those things you gotta just kind of
think about daily of like what am i
doing today yeah and just like always I
know it sounds so lame and like
something like a blogger says but like
taking time for yourself is really
important self-care self-care is
self-love we're in the era of it and you
don't realize like how important it is
until you have a huge lack of it you
also talk all the time about wanting to
have kids and like wanting to kidnap
babies out of elevators yeah I do
don't leave your child in an elevator
with me because he's coming home with me
do you have a time line in place for
when you're gonna be a mom so the other
day my friend Brian was like when you
wanna have kids I'm like like 25 cuz
that's always what I've said am i 25 is
a good time to think it start thinking
about it and then he's like aren't you
25 I'm like oh yeah maybe 30 like I like
it sucks that like I keep like
postponing it like it's gonna happen and
it's very like something that's very
much important to me like right now I'm
just riding this wave you know you got a
lot going on a lot going on people don't
hate me that much anymore like I'm
living for this time
I wake up everyday being like okay whose
day am I gonna make better che like what
am I gonna post what am I gonna say in
the podcast what am I gonna say untoward
that's gonna make someone laugh because
the world is hard enough and I'm just
out here trying to improve people's day
and then I go to bed and I put my head
on my pillow and I can rest easy
thinking that I did a good job of that
[Music]